how much revenue do you think my movie
can generate is this a smart question
for a filmmaker to ask to a distributor
or will this alienate them
that's a vital question to ask that's
the whole point of the distribution deal
is how much you're gonna
how much money they're gonna generate
you need to ask that question
and you need to hear what they answer
and you need to have them justify why
they answered it
and you know maybe they'll compare it to
other stuff that they've distributed or
other stuff that's been in the
marketplace
that's the essence of the deal it's the
essence of the whole
relationship is how much are they going
to generate
it's not all right you nice guys you're
going to go to film markets and have
some martinis and
and chit chat about my film who cares
about that how much you're going to make
that's what i really need to know you
need to ask that
and by the way you should probably if
you really want to push the deal and
don't worry about alienating
if you're going to alienate people that
easily don't do business with them
it's all business it's not personal
that's what they do for a living you're
asking them okay
here's what you do for a living can you
tell me what i can expect for you to do
for me
for a living that's not an alienating
question at all
and if you really want to push the
envelope have them put it in writing in
as an addendum here's the fork the
projections that we're projecting now
they're not going to guarantee well
they're guaranteed in a minimum
guarantee
you try to get as much of that like
they'll give you low medium and high
forecasts they'll probably go with the
medium
and you try to get as much of that in a
minimum guarantee as possible
that's the secret but beyond the minimum
guarantee
probably can't give you an absolute
number
and if they did would they would that be
honest
no they give you a forecast it's you
know like it's any business i mean you
know
it's based on our experience based on
you know the marketplace and the
conditions and everything like that
the buyers this is what we estimate
we're going to generate for you on this
film
and based on you know the quality of
your film here's our forecast for your
film
but they're just forecasts so we
hopefully will be close to them
hopefully we'll exceed them but
it's just an idea of what to expect it's
it's it's a ballpark of range are most
new independent filmmakers afraid to ask
that question yes of course they are
most new independent filmmakers are free
to ask anything to a distributor because
they're totally intimidated by
distributors
because they think distributors are for
some reason you know
smarter the holy grail or they're the
business people so you don't ask the
busy don't question the business people
you got to question everything and by
the way
what they do is a fraction of what
you've done as a
indie filmmaker what you've done in
making a movie
so far surpasses the amount of
of of passion and
and hard work that any distributor is
ever going to do
and i can speak from experience i know
what it takes to get a film made
and i know what it takes to get a film
sold now selling is a very very long
process and very difficult and you have
to be super persistent and you have to
be able to take a lot of rejection
making is super intense i mean staying
focused on story and
setting actors and all this kind of
stuff and and just getting it all
together and delivering a great product
so they're different you know
disciplines and they're both important
but don't ever think what a distributor
does is any more difficult than what you
do
and don't ever be intimidated i mean i
can't say you're going to be intimidated
by them
they're going to push you they're going
to tell you things they're going to say
and that's why that's why lawyers and
consultants exist
so that you can take somebody in who an
agent
that's what these people do they just
say things to other people that you
might be too intimidated to say to them
so you pay somebody else to say it and
hopefully they're thinking something
else
is intimidation and rejection a muscle
that can be worked
mean that this is way beyond film
discussion this is this is uh human
behavior
but um certainly
did you say intimidation and rejection
okay let's talk about rejection
if you don't have the capacity to deal
with rejection
you can't be in the film business you
can't you can't be in the indie part of
the film business you can work in the
film you can
you know be a you know gripper gaffer or
something like that or
don't be an actor that's for sure i mean
or don't be a director
anything that's super artistic or super
business related to the indie film
business
you got to make you got to be able to
deal with rejection
lots of it and you got to know how to
not take it personally
it's part of the it's part of the whole
process and the business
you gotta if if you don't have to deal
with it
you got lucky chances are you're gonna
deal with it all the time
so it's an anomaly not to deal with it
the norm is to be dealing with lots of
rejection
okay intimidation that's a personal
thing
you know it depends how confident you
are and the person on the other side i
mean sometimes they'll have position
over you
like for instance you know if you're if
you're sitting in a netflix meeting
and they have the ability to change your
life
and think about it they green light your
movie it changes your life
it changes the whole trajectory of your
life and they don't greenlight it it
changes it
in a different direction it doesn't end
your life it just you know slows it down
a little bit or something
um that can be intimidating
that's also late to the nature of the
beast um you know unfortunately and
uh you just gotta know that um
you i i relate it to poker you gotta
hand
you gotta play it the way you think is
the best way to play it and whatever the
results are that's the results and
you know you can't kick yourself you
don't want to kick yourself for playing
your hand
wrong you want to make sure after the
game's over that you feel good about how
you played
but you don't always win and you got to
remember that that you're just not
always going to win
but you got to control your tells
scratching of the nose getting worried
because maybe that affects the deal if
they realize how easily you can be
pushed around
um yeah it's funny like
i guess i'm not very easily intimidated
so it's hard for me to relate to what
you're talking about
i mean perhaps maybe i because i sat on
the other side of the intimidation
equation for so long i maybe i
intimidate more than i get intimidated
i mean it's almost a game for me to be
the intimidation thing's almost a bit of
a game it is a game sort of for me
but i understand that it's not for
everybody else and people get very
nervous and they're in environments that
they're not comfortable with especially
in those distribution
environments that can change your life
so yeah i mean i wish i was more of a
psychologist to be able to deal with
that but
you know i don't know that that is
really a behavioral psychologist
question how to deal with that
personally
what filmmaking mistake has cost you the
most money to think about that
um the money
it's funny how you ask that question you
see when you ask that question it
i it right away my mind jumps to what
production things have cost me the most
in terms of
extra costs that i've incurred but the
real question is
what opportunity cost have i lost in
terms of selling or positioning a movie
that's the bigger bigger cost lost
opportunity
so in terms of production you're always
going to make some mistakes
you know it's just human nature you
can't get everything perfect i mean
experience helps not to make those
mistakes but
and then there's situations that you
can't control weather equipment failure
stuff like that so you've got to be able
to juggle that and deal with it and you
know sometimes afterwards you say oh i
should have done this or i should have
done that or something like that or
or i missed this that's life you plan as
much as you can
you hope to deal with everything so you
try to avoid those costly errors
and i'd say you know luckily for the
most part i have but you know
you can't be perfect you can't uh you
can't bat a hundred in this game
the opportunity cost lost is you know
deals that uh it's funny we just talked
about intimidation and
and and the whole poker game and
everything like that
and i've said lots about um you know how
to push
a distributor and maybe sometimes i
probably have pushed a little too much
and i maybe left some business on the
table
because i don't like to get pushed
around so maybe i push back a bit
more than i should one could say you
know if i i'd have to do an inventory
and say
you know maybe i lost this deal and i
shouldn't have but
i got this deal and it was better than
it would have been maybe it all netted
out
frankly i haven't spent much time
regretting
i don't tend to do that i'm not that
kind of person i i
tend to look forward and not backwards
you learn from your mistakes and you
you keep them in the past you try to
remember what you learned and you moved
forward
so i i don't i don't spend a lot of time
it's hard for me to even to remember
some of the mistakes i made and i'm sure
i made lots of them
yeah it would be almost impossible to
measure a missed the cost of a missed
opportunity
sometimes you can sometimes there's uh
look at this is like negotiating a house
right
you really really really want to okay
let's say you're the seller forget the
buyer
you're the seller and you really want to
sell your house but you want a price
you want a million dollars for your
house a buyer comes in at 9.50
you go you're at 1-1 you go down to you
know
1.050 they move up to 960.
at what point and then you know then you
stick to you know
one million that's my price there they
go to 970.
if you take it or don't you take it you
said i want that i want that million
dollars
now you might not take it because you
think the next person is going to pay
you the million are going to pay you you
know
that's thirty thousand dollars that you
might be leaving on the table
and in the grand scheme it's three
percent of the purchase but it's still
thirty thousand dollars
right and you truly believe you're going
to get a million dollars
do you walk away from it if you walk
away
and you don't get another buyer you
could regret that the rest of your life
if you take the deal you could also
regret it because you'll always
second-guess whether you could have had
that extra 30
000. so it depends on the type of person
you are and how you deal with those kind
of things
i tend to say i'm going to do this
here's my deal here's here's what i want
to do
and then i put it behind me i don't
torment myself for going forward it's
not worth it
it's just not worth it but then you know
you take the 970 and the next day the
agent says oh my god you can't believe
this we just got an offer for 1.2 but
but it's too late we already signed the
other one you kick yourself
circumstances life you got to go on you
got to move you can't do that to
yourself
or the market crashes or the market
crashes you go i
did the right thing you did the right
thing so you know hindsight's 20 this is
the monday morning quarterback
you know heinz it's real easy to do it
in hindsight
you